en voici dan après les cadeaux promo de
d'un autre la haute ville gardera la
banane au coq à l'âne
loris ndao bonsoir disons pour noël les
fans bref très content l'aide parce
qu'il ya un disque un double album live
il ya un film il ya bouquin c'est là où
tu parles de 1 alors va commencer par le
début on va faire tout lapin bleu three
days ago pour noël commencé avec la
vidéo alors c'est quoi ce monsieur c'est
un film de bertrand ferait qu'on connaît
pour avoir fait du cndp baker s'arrache
est sûrement ce même terrain serbe et
meilleur long métrage court métrage
adoré enfin on peut dire fier j'ai adoré
ces images
une rencontre et ouais j'en avais décidé
de filmer un petit peu tout ce qui se
passait pendant un concert avant à
manosque et offline
intéressant c'est vraiment veut
outre mai
en fait comme on n'a pas idée son parti
remis
j'ai continué la tournée des sept fermes
coupe banane
je fais d'abord en idaho switch quand on
vit plan bien pour lui là où est-ce
qu'on est petit voyez un bouquin qui est
publié aux humanos qu'un album dans les
photos ont été faites pendant le pendant
le film en fait par frédéric b 7 avec
des textes est très bien mis en page je
sais pas qu'est ce qu'a fait ça mais
enfin c'est une fille geneviève dumas
nous est un mec s'appelle christian une
boutique boulet et c'était bien de
placer un idiot finale entre hutu 85
il ya un truc qui est pris sur le vif
aussi celle de l'album live we qui a été
fait pendant le double album qui a été
fait pendant le tour martien c'est vrai
que débute le suppliait son manager ne
pas de trouver deux concerts oui quand
j'avais fait un peu des petits concerts
mon mec devant des copains bourrés
brühlmann personnes pour comme ça ça
nous plaisait pas du tout été convaincu
mon corps et ça finit sur de sa banque
gt
parce que d'être très distant si les
pochettes et photos ces formules
d'albums comme ça très éthéré
la loire est moins tenté gym je connais
pas boutons font la gueule non mais
c'est vrai qu'il fait une musique est
très intimiste j'étais à des problèmes
d'articulation qui sont reconnues quand
même oui mais là on va en parler avec se
bat non mais c'est bizarre dont deux
dames ont fait donc c'est trop tard
maintenant comptage des cotisations
cette baisse
par exemple si aristide qui dit y a t-il
un chanteur dans la sage nous laissez
moi écouter le ministère
mais je suis pas ton côté h 10 à oued
laou même quand il chante en entend pas
mal alors mais je pense que je suis fou
dont dispose votre